I got there to his show and he had two  shirts one was black and one was white  and he said I really need you to wear  this and he held it up and it said White  lives matter and I instantly understood  the meaning behind it I understood what  he was trying to do I understood the  creative genius behind it and it it was  very crucial to make such an obvious  statement right it really was just an  obvious statement obviously White lives  matter  but it really offered a commentary on  the black lives matter movement and the  lies that we have been told about black  lives matter as being this message of  unity we're not saying that white lives  don't matter but and in reality what the  black lives matter movement organization  did was further divide people racially  and also silence people you virtually  especially in the states were not  allowed to speak if you were white you  were convicted on the basis of your skin  color this wasn't about fighting racism  this was about creating racism